[Musique]
à 57 ans Mario Pelchat souffre d'une
maladie dégénérative qui entravent ces
mouvements
n'empêche ils savourent une liberté qui
lui a bien manqué à l'ombre des barbelés
les premières années de prison je m'en
suis voulu beaucoup Mario a eu une
enfant difficile longtemps il agit ses
souffrances avec la cocaïne drogue qu'il
fallait payer il commettent un vol
qualifié et arrêté et condamné je
m'attendais pas à ce qui suivrait pour
avoir poussé un gardien en 2017
pélchant passera 29 jours consécutifs en
isolement cellulaire c'est-à-dire 23
heures sur 24
après 15 journées consécutives le nu
considère l'isolement cellulaire comme
une forme de torture la détresse que je
peux ressentir
cinq ans après son séjour au trou Mario
Pelchat peine toujours à trouver les
mots pour décrire l'angoisse qu'il y a
vécu mais il a dessiné
[Musique]
désespéré au point de s'auto mutiler
avec des lames de rasoir
je mérite qu'on soit rasoir ma famille
en 2020 les tribunaux ont condamné le
Service correctionnel du Canada a versé
plus de 28 millions de dollars en
compensation détenu qui ont vécu
l'isolement entre 2009 et 2019 les juges
ont dit que d'être isolés d'être sans
contact humain pendant 23h sur 24 ça
portait atteinte aux droits fondamentaux
et les juges ont dit ça vaut de l'argent
il faut que les gens qui ont vécu les
Allemands soit indemnisés soit compensée
dans ce cabinet du jeu Montréal tous les
jeunes avocats du bureau sont mis à
contribution dans une singulière course
contre la montre on a déjà 750
réclamants mais en fait c'est 750 sur
des milliers donc nous on trouve ce
dommage qu'il y a plein de gens qui ont
droit de recevoir une indemnité parce
que l'endroit fondamentaux ont été
violées et qui peut-être ont pas entendu
parler envie de recours collectif savent
pas qu'ils ont de l'argent qui l'aurait
dû donc le but là vraiment aujourd'hui
c'est de leur dire réclamer en 2019
l'isolement cellulaire a été abolie dans
les pénitences et fédéraux mais il
serait toujours utilisé dans les prisons
géré par Québec un nouveau recours
collectif contre le Service
correctionnel provincial cette fois et
d'ailleurs mise en branle
à Sherbrooke mario pellchat c'est mieux
de cellules judiciaires
[Musique]